now if you've listened to the show for
very long you've heard this question
Dave what's wrong with using a credit
card if I pay it off at the end of the
month because I get my points and I get
my airline miles that's what most people
do Dave
what's wrong with that well to start
with you know most people are broke so
you really don't want to emulate most
people 70% of Americans live paycheck to
paycheck they look good and they're
freakin broke but what we've discovered
over the years is simply this personal
finance is 80 percent behavior you have
to manage behavior if you're going to be
wealthy it's only 20% head knowledge and
when you spend cash hundred-dollar bills
uncle Benjamin Franklin smiling face
looking at you as you make an
expenditure it activates the pain
centers of the brain you have an ouchy
moment when you spend cash when you use
plastic you do not have that Algie
moment it does not activate the pain
centers of the brain and the results are
very clear when you spend with plastic a
credit card is the worst the next worst
is a debit card and then cash you spend
more and depending on the category you
may spend a lot more when you use
plastic McDonald's found this out years
ago that's why they started taking
plastic and now all fast food takes
plastic and it wasn't for the
convenience of the customer it's because
you spend more new study out today Apple
pay branding on vending machines
increases mobile payment usage 135
percent and overall sales by 36 percent
results of a new six month study by a
company offering Apple pay on vending
machines shows that branding specific to
Apple pay helped increase mobile
transactions and overall sales the study
offers evidence that Apple pay messaging
on the machines resulted in an increase
of mobile transaction
by as much as a hundred and thirty five
percent while transactions in general
were up forty-four percent and overall
sales up thirty six percent the vending
machines with an increased transactions
used language specific to apples payment
service prompting users to pay with your
favorite card using Apple pay another
hundred and thirty machines in a control
group used a more generic text that
simply read ready swipe or tap now 36
percent increase in overall sales forty
four percent increase in total
transactions that's huge most businesses
would do anything to get a three percent
not a forty four percent the company
published us a u.s. 80 track the sales
on thirty five of its vending machines
using Apple pays and here's their quote
based on our study we believe that when
businesses and operators present
customers with the option to pay for
items with Apple pay the number of
mobile payments made and the amount
spent increases said the senior vice
president of marketing and sales the
numbers provide evidence that negative
seasonality trends may be tempered and
even reversed by telling customers they
have an option to pay with Apple pay so
what's happened here is Apple pay evil
no Apple pay is not evil they just took
out all the friction the easier you make
it for someone to buy when you're in
business the more they will buy and the
more they will spend when they buy and
you as a consumer are just like oh that
was convenient that was easy I mean
think about Amazon Prime you just hit
the button baby you have absolutely no
friction there you instantly are
spending more and suddenly craps being
delivered to your door I had a friend of
mine kept getting odd things delivered
to his door and he finally figured out
his toddler had gotten ahold of the
Amazon button and was just hitting the
button and like they had six cases of
toilet paper show up because it was all
tied to the amazon prime you know the
button that they've got it's all about
how easy it is to buy something
I like convenience as much as the next
person I do not walk into the gas
station and pay cash for my gas anymore
I did when I was broke because I wanted
to have the exercise of realizing I just
purchased 50 freakin dollars of gasoline
and I wanted to see the $50 leave my
hand and made me think then about what I
was doing but I paid at the pump this
morning with a debit card and I do but
you don't realize you know I honestly I
cannot tell you what I paid for the
gasoline this morning I didn't even look
because I can afford it number one but
number two there was no friction there
was no sense of I just had money leave
my life and gas prices are down so I'm
not appalled or shocked at the cost to
fill up my car right now and you aren't
either and so the problem is not an
Apple pay the problem is not the credit
card the problem is you the problem is
me our response to these low friction
methodologies is that we increase our
spending and we increase the number of
transactions so well how does on proms
not evil and Apple pay is not evil and
I'm actually a customer of both so I'm
not telling you to not do that I am
telling you out loud and warning you
that the studies show you spend more
when you don't realize you're spending
because of the method that you've used
to pay when it does not register that
you have had money leave your life and
so a good exercise is just to carry some
cash and pay things with cash and it
reminds you what you are spending I mean
when you go out to eat and you'll owe a
credit card in that little black folder
you lay a debit card in that little
black folder you don't even register
what you spent on the food I had a nice
dinner with some friends last night and
we spent a pretty good-sized coin I
happen to remember that amount because
it's large enough that it shocked me and
it drilled down into my psyche
was paid with the business debit card
because it was a business dinner that
some friends and I were working on a
business thing but I'm just the same you
know you register the pain of the
expenditure and you spend less you don't
register the pain of the expenditure you
spend more and you purchase more and
that's why this mythology of oh I'm it's
harmless for me to use my credit card
because I pay it off every month no you
spend more when you use a credit card
than versus cash and so it is not a
harmless trance not a ting
revenue-neutral comparison meaning that
you can't compare say what's money I
would have spent anyway no you spend
more and this latest Apple pay study
illustrates that that when there's low
friction when you don't feel the
expenditure you spend more in this case
on a vending machine 135 percent
increase in overall mobile payment usage
that's Apple saw or increase this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]